we'll begin with this though president
Trump says he is unfamiliar with the
Justice Department's conspiracy case
against WikiLeaks founder Julian Assange
Assange faces extradition from the UK to
face charges in the United States after
British police forcibly removed him from
the Ecuadorian Embassy in London
yesterday WikiLeaks was a familiar
campaign theme though back in 2016
familiar to say the least they want to
distract us from WikiLeaks
it's been amazing what's coming out on
WikiLeaks I know nothing about WikiLeaks
it's not my thing
and I know there was something having to
do with Julian Assange I've been seeing
what's happened with Assange and that
will be a determination I would imagine
mostly by the Attorney General
he's doing an excellent job so he'll be
making a determination I know nothing
really about them it's not much it's not
my deal in life all the readers at the
White House Paulo here's something I
often have to do but I want to ask you
to do can you help us sort this out I
can major major it is fantastic to see
you at the table now clearly the love
that the president professed for
WikiLeaks didn't last but when the
president was repeatedly praising
WikiLeaks as being amazing on the
campaign trail it's because they were
releasing emails and documents that were
damaging to his opponent it appeared
that Julian Assange for whatever reason
preferred a trump presidency but turns
out Donald Trump didn't really love
WikiLeaks and it was his administration
that finally ended up charging Assange
after the Obama administration stalled
in its efforts to either charge him even
in its investigations into WikiLeaks now
we'll say this indictment the evidence
it's a bit thin that shows the Trump
administration was motivated to charge
Assange with something that it could be
hard to make these churches stick
especially without cooperation from
Chelsea Manning but federal prosecutors
have carefully crafted these computer
intrusion charges to try to blunt any
effort by Assange to argue this was all
kosher under the First Amendment wallet
picking up on that thing you said the
administration charged him with
something could we see additional
charges against Assange
a US official confirms to me major that
yes they do intend to file additional
charges against Assange his lawyer says
they're going to fight extradition but
the US and the UK have a pretty
favorable extradition treaty so I'm told
it will likely be months not years
before he arrives here in the US now he
is charged with hacking they say they're
going to fight those charges based on
the First Amendment argue that he's just
like any other journalist doing his job
but again there's no First Amendment
right to hack into Pentagon computers
already at the White House thank you
interested in the New York Times is
reporting that it was CIA director Mike
Pompeo in the troubled ministration that
has been targeting Assange